Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Olu Canne, ich bin hier DSH-Bänder erst. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Peter Sensen-Schmidt.
Können Sie bitte vor allem Nachname langsam ustabieren?
Der Nachname ustabiert sich S-E-N-S-E-N-S-C-H-M-I-D-T.
Sensen-Schmidt.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58.
58.
Wann genau sind Sie geworden?
Am 19. August 1966.
19. August 1966.
Okay, Herr Sensen-Schmidt, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Seit ungefähr drei Wochen geht es mir nicht gut.
Ich bin sehr müde zunehmend müde.
Ich werde immer müder und schlapper.
Ich habe schnell Luftnot bei kleiner Belastung.
Wenn ich etwas treppen steige, kriege ich sofort schnell Luftnot.
Ich schwitze sehr stark.
Ich habe ein komisches Druckgefühl im Oberbauch auf der linken Seite.
Ob es zu eng ist, zu viel ist, drückt es so.
Ich habe auch Druckgefühl in beiden Achselhöhlen.
Ob es da irgendwie dicker ist, geht mir nicht gut.
Wo dicker ist?
In der Achselhöhle und am Arm.
Momentan haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Vor drei Wochen hat das angefangen.
Verstanden.
Können Sie bis zum Ende des Gesprächs ertragen?
Ja, das kann ich.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Druckgefühl im Oberbauch haben.
Auf der linken Seite.
Wo die Rippen sind, wo der Rippenbogen ist.
Verstanden.
Rippenboden.
Diese Beschwerden sind vor drei Wochen aufgetreten.
Wir haben die angefangen.
Sie werden jetzt aber immer schlimmer.
Verstanden.
Hatten Sie vor drei Wochen einen Unfall?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie diese Beschwerden bei Belastung haben.
Bei Belastung bekomme ich Luftnot.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein, Husten habe ich nicht.
Beim Einatmen oder beim Ausatmen haben Sie Luftnot?
Das ist egal.
Wenn ich treppen steige, dann wird die Luft eng.
Ich muss stelle atmen und eine Pause machen.
Wie viele Treppe können Sie steigen und eine Pause machen?
Ein Treppen.
Zwei Treppen.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie Druckgefühl im Oberbauch haben.
Können Sie diese Gefühle beschreiben?
Sind Sie eine Schmerz?
Es sind nicht so richtig Schmerzen.
Es ist mehr ein Druckgefühl.
Schmerzen habe ich gar nicht so sehr.
Sind diese Beschwerden dauerhaft?
Ja, dauerhaft.
Sie haben gesagt, diese Beschwerden sind nicht belastungsabhängig.
Nein, die Beschwerden sind nicht belastungsabhängig.
Bei Belastung habe ich nur Luftnot.
Ich habe die Schmerzen auch in Ruhe, diese Beschwerden, das Druckgefühl.
Es ist auch in Ruhe.
Aber wenn ich treppen steige, dann kriege ich keine Luft.
Gibt es noch etwas, das Ihre Beschwerden verbessert oder verbessert?
Ruhe verbessert.
Wenn ich mich ruhig verhalte, dann habe ich etwas weniger Luftnot.
Aber es gibt nichts sonst, was es verbessert oder verschlimmert.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, ich habe Fieber gemessen gestern gerade.
Ich glaube, die Tage vorher hatte ich auch schon Fieber.
38,5 habe ich.
38,5.
Sie haben auch Schweiß, Schweizer?
Ja, ziemlich stark.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Der ist nicht mehr so gut.
Ich muss mich zum Essen wirklich zwingen.
Ich habe nicht mehr so guten Appetit.
Früher konnte ich sehr gut essen und hat mir alles gut geschmeckt.
Aber inzwischen ist es nicht so gut.
Ist Ihnen ein Übel oder habe Sie erbrochen?
Erbrochen habe ich nicht.
Aber manche meisen, wenn ich früher gerne Kuchen gegessen habe,
Sahnetorte, wenn ich die sehe, dann wird mir schon übel.
Die mag ich gar nicht mehr.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit der Stuhlgang?
Stuhlgang habe ich regelmäßig jeden Tag.
Wasserlassen geht auch.
Ich muss ein bis zweimal in der Nacht auf Toilette Wasser lassen.
Aber das schon seit einiger Zeit, besonders nach meiner Operation,
ist das mehr geworden.
Aber es ist für mich kein Problem.
Wurden Sie operiert wegen Vorstelldrüsekrankheiten?
Ich wurde vor zwei Jahren operiert an der Postata,
weil es ein Postata Krebs war.
Entstanden.
Wurden Sie behandelt?
Haben Sie überstanden oder Behandlung geht weiter?
Nein, ich wurde behandelt mit der Operation und mit Bestrahlung.
Aber das war dann abgeschlossen.
Und jetzt war ich das letzte Mal vor, glaube ich, fünf Monaten zur Kontrolle beim Urulogen.
Und der sagt, da war soweit alles in Ordnung.
Vor fünf Monaten waren Sie zur Kontrolle, war alles in Ordnung?
Ja.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ich habe bisher immer ganz gut geschlafen.
Aber seitdem ich so das so seit drei Wochen habe,
da schlafe ich tachsüber oft und dann kann ich nachts nicht so gut schlafen.
Weil ich auch so stark schwitze.
Da muss ich manchmal mein Hemd wechseln, ein anderes Hemd anziehen,
weil das so feucht ist.
Der Schlafer früher besser.
Erstand.
Beim Nachts haben Sie Luftnot manchmal?
Nein.
Mit wie viel Kisten müssen Sie schlafen?
Ich schlafe mit einem Kissen.
Okay.
Herr Sensen, mit haben Sie Allergie?
Gegen etwas Medikament oder Leber?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Schlafen Sie?
Nein.
Ich habe früher mal geraucht als junger Mann, vielleicht fünf Jahre,
aber schon lange nicht mehr, schon 30 Jahre nicht mehr.
Seit 30 Jahren schlafen Sie nicht, aber vorher fünf Jahre lang.
Ja, aber für fünf Jahre habe ich Zigaretten geraucht,
aber das war nicht so viel.
Mehr spontan.
Ich habe jetzt nicht 20 Zigaretten am Tag geraucht,
höchstens fünf oder zehn.
Damals, fünf Jahre lang, 20 oder 30 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Nein, fünf Zigaretten am Tag.
fünf Zigaretten am Tag.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber unregelmäßig.
Ich trinke mal, wenn ich frei habe, am Wochenende trinke ich vielleicht mal ein Glas Wein.
Aber das ist unregelmäßig.
Ich nehme jetzt nicht so viel Drogen.
Drogen nehme ich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe seit vier Jahren ungefähr einen hohen Blutdruck,
einen erhöhten Blutdruck.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie dagegen?
Dann nehme ich das Mittel heißt Walzatan.
Walzatan, ja.
Wie viel Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ich kann es Ihnen jetzt nicht genau sagen.
Ich weiß nur, wie das Mittel heißt.
Ich habe meinen Zettel leider vergessen zu Hause.
Da nehme ich morgens eine Tablette und abends eine halbe Tablette.
Mal größer, abends halbe Tablette.
Ja, dann nehme ich noch Tropfen für die Augen,
weil ich habe einen erhöhten Augendruck.
Erhöhten Augendruck, ja.
Dann nehme ich Tropfen ein, die heißen Timoptol.
Timoptol.
Nehm ich zweimal am Tag zwei Tropfen.
Okay.
Noch weitere Erkrankungen, oder?
Ja, ich habe ziemlich stark Schuppenflechte.
Schuppenflechte.
Aber das wechselt, das ist im Winter schlimmer.
Im Sommer, wenn ich ein bisschen mehr Sonne dran bekomme,
besonders gut tut mir das Baden in Salzwasser,
in der Ostsee oder in der Nordsee mal, dann wird die Haut besser.
Aber ja, das habe ich eben mal schon lange.
Nehmen Sie dagegen regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Nein, nein, nehm ich nicht.
Ja, und dann habe ich vor zwei Jahren eben Prostatakrebs gehabt
mit der Operation und Bestrahlung.
Ja, sonst habe ich aber keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Würden Sie, ja, Sie haben Prostate, die wurden vorgenommen?
Noch weitere Operation?
Ja, als Kind, da war ich, glaube ich, zehn Jahre alt,
wurde ich am Blindab operiert.
Und ich glaube, ein Jahr später an den Mandeln.
Und dann hatte ich mit 30 Jahren,
am Alter von 30 Jahren hatte ich einen Fahrradunfall
und da habe ich mir den rechten Oberarm gebrochen
und das wurde auch operiert.
Wo war das Unfall?
Wo war der Unfall?
Wo die Verletzung war.
Wann war der Unfall?
Ja, vor 30 Jahren.
Vor 30 Jahren.
Rechten Oberarm, Bruch wegen rechten Oberarm Bruch,
wo du sie operiert hast?
Ja.
Alles klar.
Herr Sassersche mit, ich komme so,
Familiennamen, sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Oder leben Sie noch?
Der Vater, der ist mit 68 Jahren,
im Alter von 68 Jahren verstorben, der hatte Blutkrebs.
Blutkrebs.
Die Mutter, die lebt noch, die ist 86 Jahre alt.
Die hatte vor 20 Jahren, hatte die Mutter Eierstockkrebs
und wurde operiert und bekam auch Chemotherapie damals.
Aber das hat es ganz gut geworden.
Also da gibt es keine Probleme.
Sie hat noch vor 15 Jahren eine neue Hüfte bekommen
wegen Arthrose.
Sie hat eine neue Hüfte bekommen.
Herr Sassersche mit,
Ihre Mutter hat Eierstockkrebs überstanden.
Ja, vor 20 Jahren war das.
Vor 15 Jahren,
hat sie eine neue Hüfte bekommen.
Sie hat eine neue Hüfte.
Hüte, Prothese bekommen.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder, 56 Jahre alt.
Er hat auch, hat man in diesem Jahr festgestellt,
Prostatakrebs.
Er wird aber nur bestrahlt.
Er wollte sich nicht operieren lassen.
Er bekommt zurzeit eine Bestrahlungsbehandlung.
Die Behandlung geht weiter.
Ja, im Augenblick läuft die noch.
Die ist noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Herr Sassersche mit, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder, 30 Jahre und 28 Jahre alt.
Die sind gesund.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Straßenbahnfahrer.
Sind Sie gegen Corona, Epatitis oder Grippe
oder gegen Kinderkrankheit geimpft?
Ja, ich bin jetzt vor vier Wochen,
habe ich eine Impfung Corona gekriegt
und eine Impfung gegen Grippe.
Gerade muss ich das immer machen wegen Straßenbahnenfahrer.
Da sind immer viele kranke Menschen.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Waren Sie in der Star-Side im Ausland?
Nein, ich war mal in Dänemark im letzten Sommer,
aber für zehn Tage in Dänemark,
Sommerurlaub.
Aber ansonsten bin ich nicht weit gereist.
Ich war immer in Deutschland.
Okay, verstanden.
Herr Sensen-Schmidt, Sie sind müde seit drei Wochen.
Beim Treppensteigen haben Sie Luftnot
und im Oberbaardruckgefühl und die Beschwerden
im linken Oberbaardruckgefühl.
Ich habe auch Druckgefühl unter den Armen,
in der Achselbühne.
Nur links Seite?
Nein, auf beiden Seite.
Haben Sie, ist Ihnen eine Knoten im Achsel aufgefallen?
Nein, nicht so richtig.
Aber ich glaube, das ist irgendwie dicker.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen geschwollenes Ball aufgefallen?
Nein, die Beine sind nicht geschwollen.
Okay.
Herr Sensen-Schmidt, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich bin etwas besorgt, was das sein kann.
Ich kenne so etwas gar nicht.
Ich bin jetzt schlecht leistungsschwach.
Ich hatte drei Wochen Urlaub.
Wenn ich wieder arbeiten soll,
als Straßenbahnenfahrer, das kann ich gar nicht.
Ich verstehe Ihre Sorge, Herr Sensen-Schmidt.
Aber genau etwas zu sagen,
das braucht einen weiterer Unterzug.
Natürlich haben Prostat-Ekrebs,
natürlich die 15-Werten,
können die 15-Werten mit dieser Prostat-Ekrebs zusammenhängen
mit der 15-Werten.
Natürlich können wir die 15-Werten mit der 15-Werten.
Natürlich können wir die 15-Werten mit der 15-Werten
mit der 15-Werten mit der 15-Werten
mit der 17-Werten,
mit der 18-Werten.
Natürlich können wir die 16-Werten mit der 15-Werten
mit der 14-Werten zusammenhängen.
Wir sind jetzt sehr leise,
wir nochmal darüber besprechen. Okay, dann machen wir. Jetzt kommt die Musik. Okay, ja, dann haben
Sie jetzt etwas Zeit, denken Sie dran, machen Sie mal ruhig so fünf Minuten, zehn Minuten.
Übersetzen Sie die Patientensprache in Fachsprache, die verschiedenen Möglichkeiten. Und die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen, es sind dann doch jetzt noch einige gekommen, haben vielleicht noch
Ergänzungsfragen. Ja, ich habe zwei Fragen. Ja. Erste Frage ist, haben Sie in letzter Zeit
abgenommen, sondern seit drei Wochen? Ja, ich habe mich gestern gewogen und ich habe ungefähr
innerhalb von drei Monaten jetzt sieben Kilo abgenommen. Momentan, wie viel wiegen Sie?
Momentan wiege ich 70 Kilo und ich bin 1,83 Meter groß. Okay. Haben Sie Herzrasen,
Engelgefühl im Brust und Windel? Engelgefühl habe ich nicht, aber ich glaube, mein Puls ist etwas
höher, etwas schneller als normal, besonders dann auch wenn ich mich bewege oder etwas anstränge.
Eine Frau hat zu mir gesagt, was sie aufgefallen ist, dass ich so blass bin. Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie Blut im Schuttul bemerkt? Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe eine Frage, Herr Schmidt. Haben Sie Schüwellungen oder ungewöhnelt
in einer anderen Körperregion bemerkt? Nein, ich habe dieses Druck gefühlt.
Da habe ich so einen Druck gefühlt. Okay, vielen Dank.
Das in der letzten Seite häufiger Infektionen hat Ihnen aufgefallen.
Infektionen? Nein, eigentlich nicht. Aber ich glaube, ich habe dieses Fieber oder erhöhte Temperatur,
habe ich jetzt schon einige Tage. Das ist mir so gar nicht erst aufgefallen, aber wie gesagt,
ich habe jetzt gestern erst gemessen und da war es 38,5. Aber mir war immer so ein bisschen,
ich habe immer so gefrostelt und ich dachte immer, ja, es geht ja halt nicht gut. Aber große andere
Infektionen habe ich bisher nicht gehabt. Ja, und hat Ihnen eine Zusammenhang mit dem Essen
und Ihre linken Oberwahrauf-Druckgefühl aufgefallen? Nein, mit dem Essen hängt das glaube ich nicht
zusammen. Dieses Druckgefühl ist immer da. Okay, und hatten Sie Schlupischwerden in der letzten
Seite? Nein, wenn ich mich nicht dran erinnere. Okay, danke. Waren Sie vor
Darmspegelung oder Vorsorge und Versorgung bei der Hausarzt? Bisher ist eine Darmspegelung nicht
gemacht worden. Mein Stuhlgang war ja immer bisher normal und regelmäßig und da habe ich eigentlich
nie Probleme gehabt. Aber es stimmt, ich bin jetzt 58, vielleicht sollte man mal demnächst
eine Vorsorge-Darmspegelung machen. Mein Hausarzt hat das auch schon vorgeschlagen, aber ich habe gesagt,
ich habe es mit der Prostata so viel zu tun gehabt, vielleicht die erste Mal abwarten. Ja, wo haben
Sie die Temperatur gemessen? Im Mund. Ist Ihnen ein Taubweißgefühl oder Kräbe aufgefallen? Nein,
ist mir nicht aufgefahren. Ein Taubweißgefühl oder Kräbe? Nein. Sie haben uns schon gesagt,
dass Sie Blasse aushaben. Ist Ihnen schwarz vor Augen aufgefallen? Sie meinen auch mit stark
Schwintel oder so oder mein Bewusstsein? Nein, das nicht. Aber wie gesagt, ich habe früher auch
viel Sport gemacht, bin auch viel gewandert und viel sehr steilige Wanderung gemacht. Das kann
ich jetzt gar nicht zurzeit. Da habe ich keine Luft für, da bin ich zu schwach. Hat Ihnen
ein rote Punkt vor mir, Haut, Erscheinung und aufgefallen? Nein, meine Haut ist natürlich durch
die Schuppenflechte. Gerade an den Beinen vorne, an den Maschinenbeinen ist die Haut schon ziemlich
verändert durch die Schuppenflechte und auch an den Unterahmen, an der Ellenbäuge außen. Da habe
ich die Schuppenflechte auch ziemlich stark. Aber keine Blutungen unter der Haut? Nein. Wenn Sie bereit sind,
können wir die gerne machen. Okay. Guten Abend. Ich habe einen neuen Patientin, Peter
Sensen Schmid, 58-jähriger Patientin, kam zu uns über Begen Fatih und Druckgefühl im Epigastrium links. Der Patient klagt über
Dyspnoe bei Belastung und die Beschwerden sind dauerhaft. Der Patient berichtet, diese Beschwerden in Ruhe besser sind.
Der Patient ist in Appätenz und heute hat er Fieber gemessen, als 38,5 Grad. Der Patient gibt an
den Stil, die Hyperhydroase zu haben. Er hat Neusea und der Patient leidet unter Nocturie. Der Patient wurde vor zwei Jahren
Prostat-Tectomy vorgenommen. Warum wurde eine Prostat-Tectomy durchgefroren? Die Diagnose war Prostat-Crabs, Prostat-Carsin.
Nach der Operation wurde er Beschwerden und Therapeut vorgenommen. Letztes Mal vor fünf Monaten war er zu Kontrolle und alles war in Ordnung. Der Patient hat keine
Anergie und die Frage nach Nikotin und Druck und Kunstung wurde verleitet.
Wie viel wiegt der Patient? Der Patient hat 7 kg abgenommen. Hat er das bewusst gemacht durch eine Diät?
Wahrscheinlich ungewollte Abnahme. Der Patient hat keine Zigaretten, aber vor 30 Jahren hat er bis zu 10 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Bei der Operation geschichte der Patient hatte eine Abhendectomy nach dem Ton-Sylectomy.
Vor 30 Jahren wurde der Patient wegen rechten Humerus-Fraktur operiert.
Der Patient hat Arteriele-Hypertoni seit vier Jahren dagegen nimmt erst Walzartan morgens ein Tablete, abends halbe Tablete ein.
Welche Dosierung nimmt der Patient? Leider unbekannt. Der Patient hat Glokom, dagegen nimmt er Timoptol zweimal zwei Tropfen ein.
Bei der Familienamnesie leidet auch ein Pteriasis.
Der Patient hat keine Medikamente, aber er berichtet, dass das Wasser ihm hebt.
Sein Vater ist an Leukämie verstorben.
Er hat seine Mutter hat eine Blutkrebs.
Er hat seine Mutter hat einen Oberkarsinon, aber gut überstanden.
Wie alt war die Mutter?
Sie war 86 Jahre alt.
Sie war vor 20 Jahren im Alter von 66 Jahren.
Vor 50 Jahren hat seine Mutter eine Hüft-Tep.
Der Patient hat zwei Kinder, 30 und 78 Jahre alt.
Er arbeitet als Straßenbannfahrer.
Er ist unerfällig vor vier Monaten Grippe und Corona-Impfung.
Er hat eine Brüder, 56 Jahre alt.
Er leidet auch Prostatikrebs, aber er wollte nicht Operationen.
Er hat eine Radiation-Therapie bekommen.
Er war in Deutschland.
Der Patient hat keinen Husten.
Ich fasse kurz zusammen.
Der Patient berichtet über ein Druckgefühl im linken Oberbauch.
Er schreibt einen Druckgefühl.
Wir fassen zusammen, was ich verstanden habe.
Er ist 58 Jahre alt.
Er beklagt seit drei Wochen eine Fatik-Symptomatik verbunden mit Belastungs-Disziplö.
Er hat die Temperaturen bis zu 38,5.
Er besteht aus hyperheterosis, eine gewichtliche Gewichtsabnahme von 7 kg.
Er ist ein Prostatak-Karzinom vor zwei Jahren.
Er wurde operiert und mit Radiation behandelt.
Er hat eine Kontrolle vor fünf Monaten.
Er ist aufhällig eine Leukämie.
Er ist 86 Jahre alt.
Er wurde mit Hygien-Therapie behandelt.
Er hat einen 56-jährigen Bruder.
Er besteht aus Atterielle-Hypertomie.
Er ist seit vier Jahren mit Walzatan, unbekannter Dosierung.
Er besteht auch von Glaukom.
Er ist unaufhällig.
Er ist aktuell mit Pulmonalephilia.
Er ist seit fünf Monaten in Ordnung.
Er klagt über das Druckgefühl im linken Oberbauch.
Er ist seit vier Monaten im Oberbauch.
Er kann eine Vergrößerte Bild haben.
Er hat eine klare Druckgefühl.
Er hat eine klassische B-Symptomatik.
Er hat eine Diagnostik.
Er kann sich schnell melden.